même les messieurs bonsoir nous sommes à
quelques 25 minutes du grand événement
de la soirée la finale de la coupe
d'europe des nations en football
allemagne belgique comme le reportage
est en eurovision et indirects pour
respecter l'horaire la présente édition
du journal télévisé se terminera plus
tôt que d'habitude à venise le
déroulement des travaux et l'ambiance ne
sont pas ce à quoi on s'attendait
en effet le message remis hier à
l'élysée pour monsieur giscard d'estaing
à propos du départ de certains groupes
soviétique de l'afghanistan
et ce avant même que l' agence
officielle au mythique taf ne donne
l'information
ce message a constitué georges bortoli
on peut le dire un coup de théâtre pour
les participants quelque chose a changé
effectivement a puni c'est vrai dans la
mesure de cette initiative soviétique et
ce sujet qui devait être un sous sol
mais plutôt qu'il devait être un sommet
largement économique pour le v10 et bien
aujourd'hui ça a été un sommet largement
politique retraites coupes soviétique
message brejnev giscard d'estaing des
détachements tout cela avec nos envoyés
spéciaux
jobs s'est dit tout de suite dans cette
affaire les soviétiques ont donc
habilement soigner leurs publicités à
l'occasion de ce sommet même s'ils ont
mis dans une certaine mesure la france à
certains moments dans une position
délicate mais mais elle permet de
relancer la question qui divise
notamment français et américains le
dialogue avec moscou
en tout cas un point et déjà acquis dès
ce soir les sept par la voix de monsieur
cossiga le ministre italien des affaires
étrangères ont publié un communiqué
commun qui rappelle naturellement que
l'occupation militaire en afghanistan
est inacceptable
d'autre part et je lis ce communiqué qui
viennent de parvenir nous avons pris
note de l'annoncé faite aujourd'hui le
disent les 7 du retrait de certaines
unités militaires soviétiques
d'afghanistan pour contribuer utilement
la solution d'archivage gagnent ce
retrait s'il est confirmé devrait être
permanent et être poursuivi jusqu'au
retrait complet des forces soviétiques
ce dernier point pour donner un gage à
monsieur cartel enfin donc pour cette
première journée du sommet de venise on
dira que les européens
alliés ont condamné une nouvelle fois la
vase en afghanistan mais elle permet
cette première journée de venise de
donner raison à monsieur schmitt et
giscard d'estaing qui font valoir leur
plus grande souplesse à l'égard de
moscou par rapport à la fermeté de
monsieur carter points donc la réaction
de jacques ces guides nos envoyés
spéciaux sur un communiqué 17
un communiqué qui vient de tomber à
l'instant même et puis là comme il faut
le dire été lu aux journalistes par
monsieur considère le président du
conseil européen puisque vous savez que
c'est vitaly qui préside
bon alors maintenant il ya des questions
qui sont incluses dans ce communiqué
première question de quel niveau la
réduction annoncée et la réduction de
quelques régiments ou est-ce que c'est
plus important ça on n'a pas de chiffres
deuxièmement est ce que c'est une
réduction définitive un retrait
définitif ou bien après ce départ de
quelques unités après quelques temps
d'attentes et bien est-ce que d'autres
unités ne monte pas venir les remplacer
la première chose à faire je crois c'est
donc un point de la situation militaire
exacte des soviétiques en afghanistan et
nous allons le faire en images avec
bruno old 26 décembre 79 l'aéroport de
kaboul un pont aérien s'achève il a duré
plusieurs jours
les entraîneurs soviétiques n'ont pas
cessé de débarquer du matériel
officiellement les pièces de rechange
pour leurs alliés afghans 27 décembre le
soleil se lève les blindés russes sont
partout c'est le goût de kaboul au début
quelques divisions 30 à 40 mille hommes
aujourd'hui les spécialistes estiment à
80 ou 100 mille les soldats soviétiques
qui luttent contre les maquis des
moudjahidines afghans
impossible de donner un chiffre plus
précis les unités vont et viennent entre
kaboul et l'ours et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui rend bras délicat toute tentative de
vérifier que l'évaluation annoncé hier
par motion a bien lieu évacuations
annoncées
on pensait au confrère que l'ours elle
est envoyé des renforts pour mater une
rébellion
chaque jour plus vive effectivement la
résistance afghane est loin d'avoir
déposé les armes si loin d'ailleurs
qu'une nouvelle grève du bazar de kaboul
est annoncé depuis hier et toutes les
échoppes de ce bazar de kaboul sont
maintenant fermés
et pourtant les soviétiques disent
qu'ils s'en vont il tient à ce que le
monde entier sache puisque ce soir la
télévision soviétique va montrer le
retrait de la première unité soviétique
de cagoules la cérémonie d'adieu une
unité qui a dit le commentateur de la
télévision qui a annoncé ces démissions
unités dont la présence n'est pas
nécessaire pour le moment
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire donc
sur le plan militaire maintenant alors
ce qui est certain sur le communiqué sur
le plan politique les soviétiques prompt
comme on dit vulgairement réussi un coup
il y a bien eus
comme on s'y attend des condamnations à
venise dollar/action l'afghanistan mais
en fin de compte l'initiative ce sont
les soviétiques qui ont fait ce qui veut
dire que lorsque monsieur giscard
d'estaing a rencontré tout à l'heure le
président carter il a rencontré un
président américain qui était un tout
petit peu pris à contre-pied
monsieur carter était venu réclamer l'
isolement de l'urss le durcissement
monsieur giscard d'estaing a pu lui
faire remarquer d'accord pour la
condamnation la france toujours qu'on
allait condamner même très durement
l'invasion de l'afghanistan
mais vous voyez a dû lui dire monsieur
giscard d'estaing que j'ai bien fait de
garder le contact avec monsieur régénère
avare seule question qu'on peut se poser
par cette initiative afghane est-ce que
les soviétiques ont cherché à diviser
les autres ils les occidentaux oui ils
ont cherché bien sûr à jouer entre les
partisans comme vulgairement de la
carotte et du bâton
mais si l'on cherchait une vraie
division une vraie faille dans cette
réunion occidental je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient vraiment gagner ils n'ont
pas vraiment gagner dans la mesure où il
ya des divergences entre monsieur
giscard d'estaing par exemple et
monsieur carter ou monsieur carter et
plus méfiants ou monsieur carter demande
que les soviétiques soit complètement
isolés tandis que monsieur giscard
d'estaing tic toujours le court on doit
passer la communication doit passer et
où monsieur je suis temps pour lui aussi
partisan de garder cette communication
puisqu'il menaces envoyées dans quelques
jours a rencontré monsieur carter à
moscou tout de même monsieur vrai venir
à moscou pardon tout de même le
communiqué qu'on nous a lu ce soir le
communiqué 17 et bien communiquer 17
la france ya pris sa part la france qui
avait déjà été à l'initiative du
communiqué très dure du 1er venise
contre l'occupation de l'afghanistan
c'est donc bien les sept qui continuent
à demander que les soviétiques évacue
l'afghanistan non pas par petits
morceaux mais qu'il finisse par
l'évacuer complètement qu'en société
autre histoire bien longtemps alors du
nouveau du côté des dissident soviétique
vladimir borissov fondateur des
syndicats libres s'est excusé depuis
aujourd'hui et il est arrivé ce matin à
vienne en provenance de leningrad part
un vol d'air au flop qui avait également
plusieurs dizaines d'israélites
autorisée a émis hier à moscou les faits
les spectateurs ont vu sur leur écran le
père du mister good co2 copte-orthodoxe
contestataires qui faisait son
autocritique il a promis obéissance
d'état soviétique et dénoncé ses propres
vivre et arctique qu'il appelle
maintenant calomnieux arrêté il ya six
mois environ il vient d'être libéré mais
il déclare en substance j'ai compris que
je vais été mis en prison
non pas pour ma foi en dieu mais pour
mon crime car je considère ma prétendue
lutte contre la paix isme comme une
lutte contre les insultes
en france nous traducteur du livre du
père du problème c'était des chefs que
voici
répondant aux questions de bruno m c'est
un vieillard il a 60 ans il a passé huit
ans dans les camps staliniens
il vient de passer six mois dans
l'isolément le plus total on ne sait pas
quelles ont été les procédés qui ont été
utilisés pour l'amener à cette
rétractation et on peut supposer le pire
souvenons nous de ce nid guerriau par
exemple il y a quelques années qui
soi-disant s'était rétracté qui avait
été libéré de suite après qui est mort
sur un lit d'hôpital quelques jours
après avoir été libéré en faisant
parvenir des messages renonce ans et 10
ans qu'il ne s'était pas rétracté nous
ne savons pas encore exactement ce qui
s'est passé s'est il renier tout le
problème est là
nous ne connaissons pas nous ne savons
pas exactement ce qu'il a dit
si j'en crois ce qui est paru dans la
presse le père doute qu a pris accepté
de reconnaître un certain nombre de
crimes jeu mais se montre guillemets
pour le père doute qu a toujours déclaré
que sa meilleure des prix la meilleure
des prédications serait son
emprisonnement
reconnaissant son propre crime anti
soviétique de 2,2 fait antisoviétique de
publications anti soviétique ou autre il
il donne par là des armes au juge qui
devrait le juger et il a l'air de dire
bon ça va
vous pouvez me mettre en prison je suis
un criminel je reconnais mes fautes
par conséquent est-ce que nous ne
veut-il pas par là continuer à prêcher
en allant en prison pour sa foi je crois
que en l'occurrence c'est à dire
aujourd'hui il faut que nous attendions
pour avoir là les propos complet du père
doute faut il savoir ce qu'il a dit
maintenant il y à une deuxième
possibilité c'est qu'ils les cas c'est
qu'ils aient cassé ce vieillard et que
qu'ils se soient rognés
mais vous savez je connais le père du
tco c'est un homme fort c'est un homme
qui me rappelle dans une certaine mesure
sa sainteté le pape est ce que vous
voyez le pape se reniant dans l'histoire
de notre plein depuis dix ans très peu
d'hommes on joue un rôle aussi important
comme cnn qui suggèrent qu'ils vous
serez perdent pas c'est à dire ministre
des affaires étrangères du président
nixon et du président john ford
tout le monde se souvient de ses
innombrables voyages à travers l'art
tous les pays de la planète et ses
spécialités qui était la navette entre
plusieurs the king jr pourrait revenir à
son poste
si monsieur reggane en traite à la
maison blanche géré gamme auquel les
sondages donnent une petite avance sur
ce cartel emery qui gère visait tiennent
encore à propos du golfe que les états
unis avaient le droit de se servir de
tous les moyens dont il dispose pour
assurer leur sécurité
demain à vis sera l'invité de
jean-pierre elkabbach et alain duhamel à
paris en direct à cartes sur table voici
un portrait de cet homme d'une stature
peu commune et aurillac caractère qui ne
plaît pas au top pendant huit ans de
janvier 1969 janvier 1977 pendant les
deux mandats du président nixon en
coulisses
à l'arrière-plan et le plus souvent en
premier plan enrique center à orienter
conseiller diriger la politique
étrangère des états unis
à l'origine c'est un universitaire
brillant professeur des rares bugs comme
le veut le métier de ministre des
affaires étrangères d'amérique
il a fait beaucoup plus de trois fois le
tour du monde à paris à l'elysée il a vu
de gaulle le colosse dit il dans ses
mémoires en 76 il rencontrait le
président giscard d'estaing juifs
il a été reçu avec tous les honneurs par
le roi khaled d'arabie farouche ennemi
du sionisme plus tard il devait faire la
navette entre le premier ministre
israélien et le président sadate
d'egypte pour réparer les dégâts
politiques de la guerre du kippour
mais son 20 heures avec nixon
c'est en neige d'abord le plus
surprenant la réconciliation avec la
chine communiste et ses scènes
étonnantes
kissinger avec chaoping johan lie avec
mao lui-même mais surtout mais dans
l'immédiat plus nécessaire la fin de la
guerre du vietnam dont les dernières
phases sur négocier discrètement dans la
banlieue parisienne avec le vietnamien
lê duc tho alors kissinger homme de paix
depuis qu'il n'est plus aux affaires il
tient des propos qui sont plus ceux d'un
faucon que d'une colons débarrasser des
responsabilités politiques est il plus
libres ou plus légers
on en aura peut-être dans quelques mois
la contrée preuve faucon colombes
si comme on le dit dire henrie devient
le secrétaire d'état de rigueur à
condition que réguler souhaité élu
président cela va de soi espagne le
gouvernement annonce qu'il ne cédera pas
à l'organisation basque était à politico
militaire et qu'il renforcera au maximum
les mesures de sécurité de prévention
contre les attentats l'été à politico
militaire avait annoncé hier nous vous
l'avons dit qu'elle avait posé les
bombes dans divers lieux touristiques du
pays bombe qui commencerait explosé à
partir de demain
10 si les exigences de l'organisation
n'était pas satisfait l'an dernier des
bombes explosent à madrid dans la gare
d'atocha et à l'aéroport cinq morts plus
de cent blessés les commandes aux
basques ne voulait pas tuer il avait
averti la police mail alerte avait été
donnée trop tard cinq morts c'est le
bilan de la guerre des plages que les
basques ont donc de nouveau déclaré
cette année au gouvernement espagnol
la bombe qui a explosé ce matin était
posée près de malaga
dans une semaine les plages seront
autrement plus peuplé et malgré les
renforts de police des espagnols auront
du mal à convaincre les touristes que
les basques posent des bombes
inoffensive pour obtenir la liberté des
membres de leur commando la fête de la
liberté organisée par l'udf au bourget a
été aussi populaire que ses
organisateurs ne souhaitait pendant deux
jours près de 200 militaires ce sont les
chiffres cités par l'organisation se
sont promenés de stands régionaux
consoeurs d'europe en passant par les
librairies des baraques foraines et les
restaurants cet après midi les deux
vedettes du spectacle ont été ou dolce
oreillettes
mais un peu plus tard le groupe santana
il a été aussi beaucoup question de
politique avec un grand débat sur la
défense des libertés dans le monde et un
discours de monsieur le cannet le
président bdf qui a évoqué la
mobilisation des militants de bdf
al'approche des présidentielles de 80 et
l'actualité diplomatique internationale
avec le sommet de venise four sur lequel
elle avait entreposé sur un dialogue
mais n'ont pas informé dialogue oui car
refuser le dialogue
ce serait consenti au retour des dangers
vers la guerre froide et peut-être vers
pire encore mais il faut en même temps
manifester la volonté de fermeté nous
avons entendu ce matin sans qu'il nous
soit encore possible porter un jugement
sur le fond de confort cette nouvelle
que l'union soviétique on retirerait
qu'elle peut tout calcalist ans il reste
à connaître l'ampleur de ce retrait il
reste surtout à savoir si ce geste est
simplement tactique et d'apparence ou
s'ils ouvrent par nous voudrions
l'espérer de nouvelles perspectives vers
une solution politique
alors la politique étrangère a tenu
beaucoup de place dans tous les débats
de cette fête
comment les militants edf résiste il
mali copains nous qui avait été abrogée
bien j'ai senti un décalage et un
décalage à propos de l'union soviétique
de l'afghanistan décalage assez nette
entre les réactions viscérales des
participants et militants et
sympathisants et la politique
actuellement suivie par le président de
la république ce matin donc il y avait
un forum important auquel participaient
en particulier un certain nombre de
dissidents soviétiques
les organisateurs avaient pris certains
risques et les dissidents eux ont joué
le jeu de la liberté puisque aussi bien
cette fête se tenait sous le signe de la
liberté ces dissidents se sont montrés
très durs à l'égard de ce qu'ils
appellent la faiblesse de l'occident
envers l'union soviétique est l'un d'eux
a même dit je cite approximativement de
mémoire vos résistants ne sont pas morts
pour qu'aujourd'hui
vos représentants ier se prosterner
devant les agresseurs ils étaient assez
applaudi par une partie de l'assistance
qui était sans doute plus sensibles à la
formule percutante qu'à la signification
politique précise et très critique de
cette formule un membre du gouvernement
a aussitôt réagi monsieur le maire les
rues en disant qu'on ne pouvait pas
parler de faiblesse ni de renoncement et
at il dit celui qui amènera valéry
giscard d'estaing à montoir ou à munich
n'est pas encore né et je crois que
c'est dans le même esprit qui est
intervenu cet après midi monsieur lecanu
est également l'occasion d'un autre
carrefour
monsieur olivier stirn secrétaire d'état
aux affaires étrangères et monsieur
michel poniatowski dans ce décalage ne
laisse aucun doute était-il pas dû au
fait que les informations concernant nos
demis temps était encore mal connues
homérique city et bien certainement on
employait tout à l'air et dans un autre
commentaire l'expression à contre-pied
je crois que les militants aussi comme
les chefs d'état des pays occidentaux
ont peut-être été pris à contre-pied
mais je crois qu'il ya quand même plus
profondément un certain problème de
sensibilité on l'avait déjà vu
il y a quelques mois lors du congrès de
l'udf cet été à ce moment là il était
question surtout de israël on l'avait vu
plus récemment il ya une quinzaine de
jours au conseil politique du cds et là
il s'agissait déjà est de lurs et de
l'afghanistan
il ne faut pas bien sûr en conclure que
les militants et les responsables
giscardien ne sont pas prêts à suivre le
président de la république et vous
parliez tout à l'heure de ce thème de la
mobilisation ou en vue des élections des
élections présidentielles où ils ont
extrêmement sensible à ce thème et puis
après tout des décalages de cette nature
on a déjà vu dans le passé notamment
sous le général de gaulle à propos de
l'algérie
à propos du proche-orient de l'okano du
québec monsieur alain goldman est élu
aujourd'hui grand rabbin de paris par un
collège comprenant les membres du
consistoire de paris représentant
différentes communes
retenez dès à présent la date d'un grand
débat public sur un thème de le 30 juin
c'est à dire demain à huit questions de
temps consacré au problème de
l'alcoolisme en france c'est vous c'est
vous qui êtes conviés à apporter votre
témoignage
et c'est le professeur jean bernard qui
vous répondra si vous désirez pouvoir
participer à ce débat écrivait à
question de temps 15 rue cognacq jay
paris 7e il s'agit je vous le rappel de
l'émission programmée lundi prochain
tiercé génèse de cette nuage de n 5 et
passants jolas pierrette brès vous en
présente l'essentiel et hier dans samedi
et demi elle vous avait montré
l'entraîneur barbe vous annonçant que
ses trois chevaux pouvait finir premier
deuxième et troisième
et ce fut effectivement le cas chose
rare ici nous avons choisi de vous
montrer les principaux obstacles à la
rivière avec des tribunes botany les
voyants sont en tête avec jeu-là 60 au
nuage de lait on revient sur la piste
intérieure et pour sauter l'open leach
voyant et devant celui de botanique
nuage de l'ennemi roulement glace et
croissants chauds qui reste en sixième
position
tous les chevaux le pas ce sens chuté
cela est un exploit car le pote on va
très vite et saute dans la foulée les
chevaux aborde maintenant le mur en
pierre l'or n'a pas changé dans le
dernier tournant les signes de fatigue
commence à se faire sentir croissants
chauds fait un effort pour se rapprocher
nuage de lait gelase cet ensemble avant
dernier rue et mais en pensant vers la
droite
regardez
tout près d'eux ce qu'elle nie roulement
y pensant chaud j'ai la scat à crozon
maintenant davantage pour venir sauter
la dernière ev et c'est alors que voyant
fatigué fait une faute et va sonder
qu'on songe reviennent très fort sur le
fleuve je la fais nuage de lait cavale
blanche mangent serre-tête rouge
s'échappe vers le poteau d'arrivée et
laisse le coton enduit bonne longueur
derrière et croissants chauds leur
compagnon d'écurie prend la troisième
place
c'est une arrivée très disputée le
tiercé 7,5 1 rapporte dans l'ordre pour
5 francs 622 30 50 et dans le désordre
pour 580 francs 50 le temps de marc est
médiocre mais s'améliore un peu plus et
verte un peu partout notre édition est
terminée mais avant de retrouver gérard
holtz 23h10 vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant en eurovision en direct
allemagne belgique la grande finale de
football
bonsoir bon football miss